foreign
letting it be known she's got a type let
the product speak for itself the mama
four rocks and I love nerds t-shirt to
the Lakers playoff game on Monday check
out her Courtside with Mom Kris Jenner
and even mid-chat with Chris's longtime
love Corey Gamble it's a great look a
look that seems like a clue into who
Kim's interested in dating as the source
told ET in April that she's now more
open to dating again and quote putting
herself out there she is feeling good
and is in a great place I really feel so
confident yeah Kim's fashion statement
also Echoes what she told James Corden
last year about the kind of men she's
going for since her split with Pete
Davidson I think my next route will I
feel like I have to do something like go
to different places clearly it's not
working whatever I'm doing right so I
feel I don't know maybe like a hospital
and meet a doctor
a law firm I think it's going to be like
scientists
neuroscientists biochemists doctor
attorney you just gotta roll with it yep
in her repeated appearances at the
Lakers game is seemingly in support of
Chloe's ex Tristan Thompson who was
recently traded to the team that's what
we do just weeks ago Kim Saint Chris and
Corey were spotted at another one of
Tristan's games where Chris gave Tristan
a big hug it's never a dull moment when
it comes to where he stands in his
relationship with Chloe a source sold ET
last month that the NBA star still loves
her and would love to be with her again
adding he's doing whatever he can to try
to prove himself to his ex and her
family but the two are not together it's
hard work for all parties I think
everyone has to handle their
co-parenting situation in their own
style but my mom and my dad were like
that it took them years but my dad would
come over once a week for family dinners
and would play golf with my stepdad and
so we come from a family where we
believe in that and you share children
with people and that's how it should be
foreign